mais dans le cadre du droit à la
désobéissance civile on évoque souvent
le côté non violent d'être désobéissance
civile et vous justement vous avez écrit
pour dire qu'au fond la résistance non
violente elle fait de plus en plus
chargées de violence est exactement
c'est ça le problème c'est à dire que
vous avez voulu dire normalement une
manifestation à c'est le cas en espagne
j'ai à dire c'est le cas bien sûr en
angleterre et aux états unis de
manifestation c'est sur les trottoirs
vous n'avez pas à interdire parce que
vous manipulez avait le droit de
manifester vos idées mais vous n'avez
pas interdire aux gens la circulation
c'est ce qui va se passer avec ce qu'on
voit des libertés chaque fois qu'on fait
un on bloque tout le monde bon bah oui
uniront manifeste qu'on est
alors une dimension fondamentale dans
cette affaire-là si aujourd'hui c'est la
médiatisation bien évidemment parce que
la violence permet de justement de se
montrer en même temps je dire il ya des
techniques de contrôle de la violence et
un jeu hein je veux dire la police met
au point des d'aidé technique de de
contention en quelque sorte de la
violence mais du coup le venir la la la
la la résistance civique elle se joue
devant avec tous ces journalistes
freelance qui sont au milieu des des
heures elle se joue je vais dire mais
médiatiquement je dirais c'est peut-être
alors c'est peut-être là que ça donne un
effet positif parce que la société prend
conscience je crois que si on les gilet
jaune s'il n'y avait pas eu la violence
suis pas sûr qu'on aurait pris
conscience de l'importance du malaise de
toute une partie de la population
française mais en même temps il est bien
vrai aussi que là on est plus dans la
résistance civique on est dans la
violence je dirais et jusqu où elle va
bon là pas pour le moment elle s'arrête
parce que elle se limite pas ce que tout
le monde met au point des techniques qui
évite bas cela dit a quand même des gens
éborgné et quand même des gens qui
perdent des mains il ya quand même des
policiers qui sont gravement blessés je
veux dire c'est s'est passé parce en
coûte 1
oui
[Musique]